est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup de femmes qui
font votre métier ici presque toute
madame toutes les femmes l'après-midi
on en a même des fois qui mène des tout
petits dans les voitures ça n'est pas
très agréable
mais combien de mois de l'année
faites-vous ce métier
couramment d'avril
novembre quand il fait beau et l'hiver
alors
c'est uniquement le rôle de la femme ou
les hommes vous êtes l'homme plutôt le
roi des hommes
est-ce que vous êtes heureuse d'être
bergère
en vous disant que la ville tout de même
c'est plus agréable de vivre quelquefois
mais j'ai appris tellement la solitude
et vous êtes à même de faire la
différence oh oui bien sûr madame vous
êtes déjà allé dans des villes vous avez
séjourné j'ai passé une quinzaine de
jours j'ai beaucoup apprécié le calme
d'accord